Moi dès que je dois aller quelque part, où quand on me donne un rendez vous
Y'a un truc qui est sûr c'est que je serais toujours à l'heure.
FAUX !
J'suis toujours en retard...
Pffff... Ouais c'est vrai que j'suis toujours en retard.
C'est super chiant et en plus j'fais pas exprès et les gens m'engueulent.
Mais, si jamais j'suis toujours en retard, je me suis rendu compte que c'était à cause d'un mec.
C'est à cause du mec qui a inventé la touche "répéter dans 5 min" sur les réveils.
Tu la connais cette touche ?
(Musique de réveil)
Oh putain !
(Musique hardrock)
Mais en plus elle sert à rien cette touche, sérieux.
T'as dormi pendant 8 heures, t'as pas besoin de 5 minutes en plus !
Excuse-moi, j'ai pas compris ce que tu viens de dire, non parce que je suis bilingue.
Ah oui, pour les bilingues, cette touche s'appelle "Snooze".
Ah, snooze. Ah la touche snooze, ah ah, amazing !
Y'a une autre raison pour laquelle j'suis souvent en retard
C'est qu'à la seconde où je dois partir
J'ai toujours envie de faire un truc mais que je ferais jamais en temps normal...
Allez, c'est parti !
(Pense dans sa tête) : Mais, c'est quoi ce pied de table bancal ?
Faut absolument que je le répare !
Ok, c'est bon, j'peux y aller !
En plus, dans ces moments là, j'suis stressé parce que j'dois partir
Et j'sais que j'suis en retard tu vois, et j'me mets à faire des trucs, euh, un peu chelou.
Est-ce que j'ai bien fermé la lumière de la salle de bain ?
Moi j'arrive pas à partir, zen, serein, l'esprit libre, tu vois
J'ai forcément besoin d'être en stress et en panique pour y'aller quoi.
En fait j'crois j'ai besoin d'adrénaline. (Rigole)
(Musique épique d'adrénaline)
Y'a un truc que j'comprends pas
C'est que quand es en retard et que t'arrives en rendez-vous, t'as couru, t'as sué, t'es en nage, t'en peux plus
T'as tout donné, t'étais dans le stress, la panique et, et t'arrive devant le mec, tu vois
Tu t'écroules et tu dis "ça y est, j'suis arrivé"...
Ben le mec y t'engueule.
Putain mais à ce moment là, tu mérites juste une médaille quoi !
Ouh, j'suis en retard de 50 minutes, les mecs !
(Musique We are the champions Queen)
Le pire, c'est au travail, j'me fais toujours défoncé.
Et faut savoir que dans le milieu du travail, t'as pas le droit d'être en retard
T'sais pas pourquoi, mais quelques secondes, c'est pas possible.
Dans la tête de ton patron, c'est forcément "NON!"
Alors j'ai essayé toutes les excuses du monde, mais laisse tomber ça marche jamais.
Ah... excusez moi Monsieur, c'est, c'est  la touche "SNOOZE"
(Buzzer)
Alors que, j'sais pas si t'as remarqué
Mais les filles quand elles trouvent une excuse, ça marche toujours déjà
Et deuxièmement, c'est quoi ces excuses nulles ?
J'suis vraiment désolé Monsieur, mais ce matin, j'étais pas très bien...
Tu t'sentais pas très bien, mmmouais, c'est pas mal comme excuse ça.
Ouais bon, ok, ça marche, allez on oublie tu peux rentrer, ha ha, excuse moi.
C'est génial ça, pas très bien.
Alors comme mes excuses, ça marche jamais
Moi je pratique un truc, c'est le semi-mensonge.
J'sais pas si tu connais
c'est que à la fois tu mens pas vraiment mais en même temps t'abuses un peu quand même.
Par exemple t'es super en retard à un rendez-vous
Et à la seconde où tu poses ton premier pied dehors
T'envoies un message au mec qui t'attend
"J'arrive, j'suis en chemin"
Ça s'appelle un semi mensonge.
Bécassine, ah... Ok...
Y'a des gens qui croient que quand t'es en retard
Tu fais ça exprès pour te la raconter tu vois
Parce que c'est un peu cool et tout, non, non, c'est pas cool...
Excuse moi René, j'suis un peu en retard
J'suis complètement chéper, j'ai pas regardé l'heure, bah d'ailleurs je sais pas lire l'heure...
Haha, Hein ? Ah non, t'es viré, tu te casses ?
(Ricane) Ah c'est parce que non, j'suis pas chéper, j'suis pas chéper, je rigolais, haha...
T'es viré, tu te barres maintenant, et je fais la forme du pistolet, ok ? Donc maintenant tu t'en vas !
Maintenant que j'suis devenu un adulte
J'ai enfin compris que, en fait pour être à l'heure, c'est pas compliqué
Ça demande juste un seul truc, ça demande du courage.
(Mec qui chante le générique de Pokémon)
J'ai vu que vous étiez plus de 30 000 sur la page Facebook Norman fait des vidéos
Et je me suis dit peut-être que, ça pourrait remplir un stade de foot
Et qu'un jour on pourrait faire un match